Oh what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Island sake on
very excited to be talking about gender
relations talking about neo-traditional
ism we have Katie Schuler joining us on
the show hello hello thank you for
having me thank you for coming on really
appreciate it very excited there's a lot
to unpack about this subject and really
pumped there's so much nuance that we're
gonna get into those that don't know
Katie's background kidneys links are
below
she's a Neos Sybil Seibel Nia Sybil neo
Sybil which is an Oracle new Oracle
nihilist an anti-theist
rationalist neo-traditionalist monogamy
advocate and singularity m-- yes he's an
advocate of the singularity yes yes
Katie's very excited for AI to just you
know oh yeah yeah yeah I'm ready for the
robots to take over we're gonna talk
about that okay tell us this big history
perspective here we are as stewards of
Earth what's your current take on the
state of humanity um I think that we're
suffering largely from an oedipal
complex or at least I think most people
are edible Oh oedipal complex a taboo
like and not edible like Oedipus Oedipus
Oedipus yes he's just what Oedipus okay
so well like the for those who don't
know the story of Oedipus is you know
basically or at least it's used as a
metaphor in Psychological terms the the
fear of your own progeny so being afraid
that like you know your son will kill
you and marry your wife which is
obviously very horrific but I think that
a lot of people suffer that idea when it
comes to technology innovation
automation and artificial intelligence
I believe that artificial intelligence
is our progeny I think that we're moving
towards a direction where we're going to
ascend biological existence and I think
that when people reject this and in a
lot of the fear rhetoric around AI and
so on is really just an issue of an
oedipal complex wearing people are
afraid that they're going to be made
irrelevant
or that they're not going to be able to
you know make it through that threshold
because you know as we go into new
frontiers and evolution of course
there's always the weeds that get picked
out there are people that aren't able to
evolve and adapt and that's what a lot
of that is in my opinion well yes so
it's that this is our child is the
artificial intelligence and that we have
we have to do some work in embedding it
we don't we barely know our own ethical
codes that our moral codes that are
really strong that we want to we need to
embed into the AI into the children so
that we don't end up getting bombed or
or you tell us about that process book
what's the good code to pass down
holding make sure we don't get bopped is
it okay if we get bopped
well I think that we just need to accept
that that some people aren't going to
make it and that's that's that's
necessary for evolution it's necessary
for you know there to be ones that do
adapt and ones that don't and if there
isn't that challenge and there isn't
that that that hurdle to climb then we
don't make any progress and that's when
we die out that's that's when you go
extinct and you know we need to adapt
for that in fact that's my explanation
for like the Fermi's paradox is that we
haven't found alien species out there
because I think that once we get past a
certain point as intelligent life that
we ascend our biological forms yeah and
so basically anything else that's out
there isn't paying any attention to us
because you know if we're still monkeys
like you know why would they were still
monkeys that are killing each other and
making each other miserable all the time
and
until we pass that threshold I don't
think that we're going to find the other
life that is out there if one is so
inclined to call that life yeah it's
like the zoo hypothesis that you gotta
like do your to make AI you yeah it's
kind of soft before you can break out of
the cage and others will pay attention
yeah it's a little bit of a
collaboration of a couple of different
thoughts but yes interesting so then the
you said that's necessary to have a ones
that don't adapt and that them for it to
die off yes yes I mean if everything is
so easy where everyone makes it through
that threshold then it's just it's not
evolution it's not progress it's not you
know if there isn't that challenge and
that waiting of the garden
that's selecting out of inferiority then
we can't ascend we can't progress we
can't move forward yes
can we go extinct so so selecting out of
inferiority now okay and that's kind of
what we've been doing is we've been
progressing away from inferiority more
of the maybe like primal you know to
less of the primal more of some sort of
an ethical or moral let's say
civilization and along the way though
one could also potentially argue that
some of what is viewed as maybe inferior
is the the seed being rotten in some way
because it maybe it hasn't had the right
nutrients or the right the right
protocols that have enabled that seed to
flourish and then the seed may not be
inferior yeah so then we could maybe
have it well it isn't necessarily
something that's instilled it's like
inferiority can be something that is
just an inferiority of means so you know
if you're not able to acquire certain
opportunities if you're not able to
adapt and if you're not able to find
yeah if you're not able to find the the
means to do so
then that is your inferiority okay I
hear you on the means but then can't
genetic engineering or brain computer
interfaces give people the means
to be a part of the well certainly but
then the inferiority comes down to
people who are naturalist so then those
are the people that are going to get
weeded out so it's like we can always
change the the circumstances and in how
we go about doing things and trying to
advance ourselves but that's just going
to change how we select we're not gonna
leave any room to breathe for naturalist
like naturalist can't just go live and
they Amazon if they want to they can try
[Laughter]
I mean I just don't think that you're
like you're not gonna be able to pass
that hurdle you're not going to be able
to ascend as I said I think that the new
frontier as far as evolution is for us
to you know ascend biology and you're
not going to do that if you're you know
getting killed in the rainforest so so
if even if even if the that's visible
this choice of Ascension through through
the singularity with artificial
intelligence and then the naturalist
path of I just want to be in my biology
that hopefully we can maybe leave some
space for that but people certainly the
space exists I just don't think that
they'll succeed in that ascension
plainly okay so you may become divergent
maybe it'll become something else okay
so you don't ascend as much okay sure so
so it could be I think that is our our
own human ascension is is to you know
you know ascend our biological forms but
hey you know maybe we might become a
divergent species and in that you know
there might be some other biological
existence for humans and you know one
that's you know one that's biological
and one that's not
yeah yeah okay now let's go into you
know who you are because you know you're
you got this this is a great sort of
first stain its synthesis on humanity
pardon me and my tangents so so now you
know you're born here in Silicon Valley
yes and you grew up in a very
conservative family but in a very
liberal in a religious family as well
yes
but in a very liberal area which i think
is very interesting because i kind of
did a conservative south dakota to a
liberal minnesota to it even more
liberal Silicon Valley so I had a very
moderate as well I turned moderate in
this sense of her independent of free
thinking because you got to see both far
both ends okay yeah so tell us about
this well it was it was nice because you
know had I grown up here but not had
that upbringing then I would probably
hold a lot of the values that are
indicative of this area but not really
have those values in the sense to where
be able to hold them without them being
challenged as you know a lot of people
out here have I'm sure you've met them
and you know your are you really right
if you don't understand how you came to
that conclusion if you don't if you're
not able to defend or explain that point
you're not doesn't you know even if you
have been to arrive to the correct
conclusion so fortunately I've you know
had very polar exposures which have
allowed me to basically spend a lot of
my life challenging everything I think
and everything I feel and you know got
me into debate and self educating my you
know self and as far as trying to
constantly change my own opinion change
my views and have those views be
contested yes yes so debate was a
crucial part of the bringing as well I
mean I wasn't a part of my upbringing
but it was definitely something that I
was drawn to while I was in school yes
oh yeah I I and I lost a lot of friends
I lost a lot of friends that way I
repeatedly get into situations where you
know there would be a prompt that was
given to the class as far as two
different opinions to like to contest
and the teacher would give like a dumb
prompt where like it really felt like
that the answer morally was very obvious
and so obviously everybody would you
know pick that side the you know the
easy answer that they personally held
and me I've always liked to be the
devil's advocate and would be debating
and tied against my entire class and
this happened several times and I lost
many of friends and because of that all
of my friends while I was in grade
school were either older than me or
younger than me generally speaking and
that if you were in the same class as me
you did not want to be my friend some
other interesting things on that route
where you said that you you you you you
should know how you got to the way that
you think yeah so what were the stimuli
that influenced you and not specifically
you but a human how did how did they get
to the beliefs that they hold today what
stimuli influenced that belief so if you
can then go back and explain how you got
to that then that makes that gives you a
deeper grounding in what you currently
think and then also you mentioned
challenging kind of like Authority a
little bit and like Oh in a way of if
someone's saying you know believe some
things like why why should I believe
that way Oh certainly I'm sorry I'm not
really sure if there was a question in
there to you do those two things that
you mentioned earlier I just thought
were really oh yeah we're really yeah
we're really crucial things certainly so
then how did you pick up your interest
in federalism versus you know popular
sovereignty how did you how did that
come into your life um well I think that
there's a lot of basically junk in our
government a lot of policies and and
whatnot where you look at it and it
clearly doesn't work and you're like
okay well like it had to work at some
time it had to have made sense at a
certain point so I have the habit of
looking at you know a certain policy or
a certain party or you know institution
within our government and then go on to
the tangent like what was its you know
what is it the successor of and where
did that come from
because it all kind of branches out so
it's important to know how things came
about to be if you're going to
oppose something or support something
yes yes okay and then the so now there's
a this is very important you got to look
at the code at which you live in and
then try and find what you want to
update and maybe get rid of and so
certainly because there could be parts
that like they're gonna be parts of
something that maybe are still
functional and still working but maybe
we diverged at a certain point because
something was functional that at the
time and doesn't work anymore or we
diverged in a way that that you know
didn't work at all but so much of it
still does work and so I think we really
need to re-examine a lot of the
different you know policies that have
been implemented and where about they
came so that we can not only correct the
errors but make a point to not undo a
lot of the good because we do have an
excellent country here and we have an
excellent culture here and I think
trying to dismantle the whole thing is
is absurd and I think trying to keep it
rigid or just move it forward is also
absurd I think that we just need to be a
little bit more strategic and and
thoughtful about how we go about that
okay so with a you know a federalist
perspective of having a country
government of federal government and
state governments and then potentially
having elected representatives
representing you versus being able to
maybe have a general population that can
be educated enough to participate in the
country's updates yeah well I I think
the the important thing to understand
about when we try to be Federalist and
kind of let the the US government take
over everything is that we need to
understand that we're a very large
country and we have a lot of different
cultures and things that make sense for
some people don't make sense for
everyone and it's okay for people to you
know be isolated from other parts of the
United States and it doesn't necessarily
make them regressive and I think that
jumping to that conclusion is really
it's unfortunately ignorant I
ironic way of letting the poly the
cultures kind of play but but like
giving some the freedom of speech right
there's a one that works for everyone
and then there are certain codes that
don't work for everyone like give us
some examples of what works or some
people maybe what wouldn't work for
other people oh let's see
maybe there hypothetically would be like
some states where polyamory should be
more accepted and some states were
polyamory you know should necessarily be
legal while I tend to lean towards
libertarianism and like to give people
as much freedom to do as they please and
so on and so forth I could understand
how there might be some states where
relative to the male to female ratio it
would be sensible to be permissive in
some ways and relative to like cultural
and economic structures in another state
it would make sense to criminalize it to
say defend the the the the right that
every man has to have like his own
partner and that's that's like one of
the arguments for monogamy is just that
society functions better and there's
less aggression in males and males are
more productive and can build on society
a lot more and do build in society a lot
more when they have the prospect of I
you know I get to be a good man I get to
find a woman because I am a good man
because I will be a good man for that
one yes we were touching on this in the
last conversation as well so so there's
a in some ways of crisis of meaning
happening in in very developed places
where we're getting extremely attached
to videogames or drugs or whatever it
may be that is giving us quick the
dopamine hits versus maybe planning out
long term some sort of a divine purpose
of our life and that being bridged
together with a another with a female
with a partner right so
and then having a family and having kids
and working for them to have meaningful
lives and fulfilling lives that those
things are all extremely interconnected
and so your your you know your
understanding of that gender relation is
that is that those are extort that those
are crucial for the family and that then
in your wherever you live in your
pockets you can kind of have a depending
on the belief systems of those areas can
they can they can write their own well
this is one of the areas of where I
oppose I opposed the feminist rhetoric
because a lot of the feminist rhetoric
is that men and women need have equal
power or at least men can't have greater
power than women in any department and
we're always constantly trying to create
equity between the sexes as far as we're
you know men are succeeding women and we
don't do the same for women succeeding
men yeah so we deal with the situation
where there's there's you know women who
are you know climbing the the caste
ladder and so on and so forth as far as
you know out earning men and doing well
in school and while I'm very happy for
people to be ambitious and to you know
seek out those ambitions I don't think
it's appropriate for us to be pushing
women to be moving in this direction
being that women the way that gyno
hypergamy works hypergamy the way the
women are high Pergamus works is that
they you know they want a man that can
protect them and defend them and we
can't just rip that out of our coating
at least we can't presently so the
the pool that women are willing to date
gets smaller and smaller and smaller
than as women try to get you know parity
with men in these departments is that
you know as you climb up and it's great
for you to be successful but that's also
going to shrink the pool of men in which
you probably find a feeling find
appealing unless you're willing to you
know fight against that that instinct of
hypergamy and you know be be a female
CEO who's dating a pizza delivery guy so
so we can we can see this as as as the
as a female climbs up a hierarchy and is
is then realizing that the pool of
appealing candidates yes shrunk in size
because they want they want to also date
up and and then them being so high up
makes it more difficult for them to find
em certainly since it doesn't increase
their value it doesn't increase the
amount of men that find them appealing
it like at best it gives them greater
access to maybe hypothetically the men
that they want you know if women goes to
university she gets to you know meet
university men you know if women's
working within a certain office space
she gets to meet them you know the men
within that field which you know that
can be its own advantage in in certain
ways but as a woman climbs up like men
aren't high pergamus when it comes to
caste so as you go up and the pool of
men being desirable they're not men are
not hypergamy so many caste men are high
pergamus in a biological respect they
want to seek out women who have better
genes women who have a larger
reproductive window so on and so forth
so that's like aiming for a younger than
for the law or just women who display
more neoteny as to indicate that she has
a broader window
other women because okay so it's sadly
age isn't necessarily chronological
when it come when if we're gonna be
honest about our biology is that some
people age faster than others relative
to their genetic makeup and relative to
their life choices so it's you know not
exclusively chronological it's it's you
know aging as far as you know whether or
not a woman is jnanis so a man you know
won't want a woman with you know good
genes a larger reproductive window but
as a woman climbs that you know that
ladder as far as education and career
and so on and the pool of men that she's
willing to date gets smaller and smaller
her value doesn't go up and she's still
getting older
interesting there seems to also be maybe
part of it is has something to do with
the way that we find cultural culturally
how we find people interesting like
sapiosexual czar focused on intelligence
being the thing that goes past
everything else and i think that i think
that's a very interesting way to think
about it too is that when when we're
looking at things in a very old-school
like biological system which has been
around for a very long time obviously
and it's very like you were like you've
been explaining it's just extremely at
play in our in our world at the same
time there are potentially new cultural
dynamics that could come in at play that
kind of throw things but you're right
there's a lot of people that are not
getting the partners that they
potentially want with the ways that
things are changing and i think that's
an important conversation to totally to
unpack and and have what would you
propose as as solutions to what well i
think that we need to stop telling women
that you know that they need to
necessarily climb those ladders i think
certainly that that freedom that liberty
and room for women to do so you know
should be available and you know we
should be supportive of those women we
should cheer them on we should be proud
of them but we also should be honest
with ourselves and saying like okay well
that probably means that you're going to
have less opportunities in this
department
and as long as we're honest about things
and honest about what the consequences
of what that will be then women can make
more educated decisions as far as what
what are my actual ambitions what are my
goals because if a woman is you know
prioritizing you know having a family
and so on and so forth maybe she doesn't
want to go that direction or maybe if
she's you know attracted to you know a
certain type of man or a certain cast of
man then she needs to focus on that goal
so it's it's really just being honest
about what the consequences of those
individualistic choices are for women
and allowing women the freedom to make
those decisions for themselves but not
doing so in a dishonest way know thyself
yeah okay so if you do want to pursue
mimetics then you may decrease your
potential mating pool along the way yeah
well yeah you just yeah you're
decreasing the pool size yes if you're
gonna climb up the caste system then
you're gonna you're gonna if the the men
that you find attractive will be lesser
and lesser lesser because fewer men will
actually be beneficial relationships are
hard they're challenging but men can
also climb up simultaneously providing
that maybe that more so if they're both
kind of climbing up if both are pursuing
mimetics or careers then there may
potentially be also slow potentially at
the same pace that men are going up
could potentially be at the same pace
that women are also climbing up the
career yeah well that so long as a woman
in a man is like you know equal it's
it's not it doesn't really work as far
as her
hypergamy and her being attracted to him
so I'm not necessarily saying that she
becomes less desirable to the man by
climbing up those ladders that I mean
that there are some arguments to be made
that men are less attracted but the
focus is that there's going to be fewer
men that she's attracted to that she's
interested in because relationships are
challenging and because he has to add
benefit and the benefit that women look
for in relationships is you know
somebody who can
butan somebody who can help support her
offspring whether or not we've passed
that we haven't evolved past that we're
still there and we still have the those
bases of Attraction I want to be able to
afford to impregnate as many different
women from different cultures as
possible I'd like to maybe get a
GoFundMe account you know have a just
different cultures different women have
them all get along you think that's the
pollinates firm well I just rather have
the family element you know just one big
happy family
yeah children and they speak the
languages of their brothers and sisters
that's you know gonna be nice but I'm
taller they got something for you man
it's called sense that it's an
interesting thought experiment and and
all the different permutations of
children that you could potentially have
being a part of the school that you
would make I think can help honey and
then maybe even women being able to do
that oh I want to have babies from 30
different men is that a crazy thing no I
mean women women appreciate like the
advantages of genetic diversity just as
much as men do as far as from a
strategic standpoint the only the only
thing that hurts women in that effect is
that they have a very long gestation
period especially relative to other
species you know run nine to ten months
depending on what your ethnicity is and
then taking care of it as it yeah and
also just the consequence of losing out
on the opportunity of monogamy with you
know men you know if you're if you're
not exclusive for yourself
and you're not going to get access to a
guy's resources you know this is all so
complicated and so interesting the
gender relations okay this is gonna
trickle in as we continue talking what
is you know the relation of of the
genders in the hierarchy meanwhile there
is this kind of this this weird way that
we've been
kind of in some ways we were talking
about sin last episode that what's what
what's going on with this intern
indentured servitude saved Demick yeah
I'm sure servitude relative to to like
institutionalized like federalists use
junk okay so as we implement more
socialist structures a particular a good
example of being public education we're
taking kids away from their their
parents because you know we're already
having them pay for it so they're not
going to you know cash out you know
they're not going to abstain from
cashing out on that quote-unquote free
babysitting but as you as we do so we
take mothers away from their children
and children away from their families
and they're constantly you know we keep
them working and as we keep them working
people keep on falling under the
impression that they can't afford to
take care of their own kids that they
can't afford to have a single income
household and it's just not true it's
just not true that we you know we can't
afford to raise our own kids because a
lot of the a lot of the the jobs that a
mother does when she's home
people end up outsourcing you you know
for instance you know we we make a lot
of we okay like cleaning products that
we have inside of our household back in
the day women knew how to make a
cleaning product just fine you know
using you know vinegar and baking soda
and different products like women knew
how to clean that there was women were
chemists they were they were domestic
like economists and they were able to
balance all of these tasks as well as
educating their children and paying
specific attention to the educational
needs of their children and now we're
missing out on that and we keep on
thinking that we can't afford things
because there's this huge inflation in
the price of these different things that
we need like basic cleaning household
items where you know you're paying
for $5.00 for something that costs 10
cents yeah the way you just connected
everything was super interesting okay so
so our taxpayer dollars are going to the
education in in our local areas and that
we want to take advantage of of that but
at the same time we need babysitters
because that the child can be babysat
for eight hours while they're at school
while we work anyway we have to work
those hours now why doesn't public
school have the same time as the basic
work schedule works good does it yeah so
it obligates them yeah it's a little
awful on both ends but then then you
also mention this interesting point
about how you know women being chemists
women being economists women being um
take it's paying super close attention
to their child's particular needs
particular needs and that that but and
when you're there at work they're not
doing that for those eight hours right
or men aren't either or however you want
to paint this picture that when when
that that the family dynamic of being
with a child and helping the child
understand who it is and have their have
have their creative endeavoring really
truly explored it's harder to do when
you kind of push it off to a school
system than when you can take on that
responsibility yourself but then like
we're in servitude towards this to the
machinery of the economy where we have
to go and work in order to make money to
pay our rent and to so this is this is
kind of a and one set is like the the
syllabus is just this cookie cutter
one-size-fits-all and children are
missing out on the particular attention
that they used to get so you know if
your child has certain gaps and
shortcomings you know they're they're
not going to be attended to the same way
they would have you know if you know you
have the homemaker there and taking care
of said child and not only that but you
know kids are learning a lot of things
that maybe necessarily aren't practical
for them you know a lot of people are
learning math that they never use out in
the real world or and but they're also
to do a lot of math that they never
learned in school so you know the
particular attention not only relative
to that child's needs but relative to
the specific culture and specific area
where and you live to where you can move
your child forward as far as actual you
know prospects and you know something
that's actually going to be useful help
actually move them towards the career
and the skills that they need to survive
where they're at especially relative to
their particular needs
what does then the what does the what
does affirmative action in this double
tax tactic double taxation of income
have with what you were just describing
okay
so unfortunately as men and women are
living more and more separate lives and
that a lot of the time they have their
own careers and they have separate
careers where a lot of people are
spending time with you know some other
people especially sometimes even people
of the opposite sex more than their own
spouse and too often do I hear the term
you know this is my work husband this is
my work wife and you know it's the sad
truth and I think that probably most in
fidelity's that occur within a marriage
often take place at the workplace just
because you know if you end up spending
a lot of time with somebody then that
person does become your partner yeah
well more time with the work husband or
work wife yes hate your own life or
husband yeah oh yeah and that especially
happens for people that are lower and
you know on the economic cast people you
know because they're you know they're
working a lot more hours and they they
tend to be in careers where there's a
lot more like a lot more gender mix-up
where like you know there's 50/50 both
men and women within those work fields
and as they you know are a separate from
each other their marriages fall apart
they get divorced and you know they seek
out their own individual lives and they
live in separate homes as they live in
separate homes they the demand of the
demand of space the demand of you know
homes and residences goes up but the
supply doesn't go up so it becomes less
affordable to you know to even have a
home
and so people are working harder and
harder and working more hours to try to
keep up with that and as particularly
the men they're creating more and more
in
the alimony that's taken out not only do
they get that income tax do they receive
an income tax when they make that income
for themselves but when it goes on to
their spouse there's an income tax on
that and that is paid for and due to
recent legislation the payor is the one
paying the tax both times
so we're paying for two housing
properties we're paying for two sets of
everything in the in the house we're
paying this is getting it this is
getting crazy already and that's why
about well that's the cycle of
indentured servitude that we live in is
that people keep on getting tricked into
these schemes and pushed into these
systems where they keep on thinking life
and everything is less and less
affordable just by making these
decisions where they're just separate
and that's why men and women really need
to come together again and they need to
be more honest they need to communicate
with each other and we need to be more
honest to women about how to acquire
their happiness and how to acquire their
goals
yeah this honest dialog is extremely
important but it's also super complex
because how does how does one you know
in an 8 billion person society one one
finds themself wanting to you know to to
be of of impact right one wants to
whether it be just impacting one person
you know that's impact or impacting the
world with some moonshot thinking right
there's a lot of people want to follow
and so a lot of people are trying to
follow into that like moonshot thinking
but in order to actually execute on
moonshot ideas you kind of have to live
in the way that potentially puts this
idea of genetics of procreation or
partnership at at a secondary point and
if you do that then you're typically not
living with the partner you need to be
living in separate places and only see
each other maybe once well we need to
stop incentivizing women to to abandon
and their families and break up their
homes because if you look at the
statistics on you know who's initiating
divorce it's women like by strides it's
it's like it's not even close this is
the u.s. yes yes
women women it just absolutely exploded
when no-fault divorce was implemented
and so women are divorcing and leaving
their husbands and trying to take the
resources and I think that a that we
need to stop financially incentivizing
women to break up homes and additionally
we need to protect the rights of men as
far as their consent to creating their
own progeny is that too often women are
having a man's child without his consent
and even when it's agreed upon that you
know we're not gonna have kids or we're
not gonna have kids yet women are doing
so anyway and this is allowing the woman
to hold the man financially hostage
and it's in my opinion it's its own form
of sexual abuse against men and I think
that we need to accept the fact that
children are the biological property of
women and I think that paternity from a
legal standpoint should only be existent
in the case where the man consents to
having that child so some people are a
big fan of the paternal surrender some
sometimes it's even called financial
abortion where a man is not responsible
for a child and he's able to revoke his
responsibility my attitude is that a man
should have to consent to that
responsibility in the first place so
children should be considered the
property of women and the father or
whomever is interested in helping in
rearing that child should have to
consent to it my biological dad would
have been all over that yeah sure but he
would have lost design he did anyway you
know he felt that it wasn't a question
of need it was a question of want on
behalf of my mom and he it was just what
he did was lose his children no longer
carry his last name so yeah well I
consider it sexual abuse against men and
it's rampant like how many people do you
know who had you know at least
themselves or one of their siblings that
the father did not consent to
particularly the first child
hmm women know that they're going to be
held responsible and that they can't
hold a man hostage I think that women
will be more responsible with birth
control and they'll be more responsible
with their mate selection and so on and
so forth yeah yeah the responsibility
with birth control and mate selection
that the catalyzing that's interesting I
also think that just based on a straight
up like like just on a like educational
level for both of the parties to just
know that hey are we trying to have a
child right now and they answer and
being no okay
we will do everything possible that is
needed to not have a child right no like
this just needs to become more of a
commonplace because then you don't get
the oops scenarios that were even
talking about right now
oh yeah men men don't have the right to
abort their child yes and it would be
absurd for us to afford men that right
that's that would be absolutely
disgusting you know what are we gonna do
tie women to a table so women have the
ball in their Court it's your body you
get to choose whether or not you get
pregnant well in most cases at least to
some extent you know the women are the
ones who have the control over that
situation so why do women have full
control and men can't even opt out of it
they men can opt out by just withdrawing
themselves pre orgasm like it's not that
hard I think - well there's there's
there's tampering birth control there is
that women have more options when it
comes to birth control there's in the
case where birth control fails or
accidents happen that women have the
option of having an abortion while I
don't think that we should run on you
know you know we've if you don't want to
kid just you know have an abortion like
you know some women find that
disagreeable and it's fine for them to
find that disagreeable but if women have
the large amount of control in that
situation then we need to at least
afford men the control of saying you
know all right that's fine you can you
can have a kid or not having a kid but
I'm not responsible for it unless I
decide I am Katie just the fact that you
know that this is coming for the first
time to my entire life right nice and I
say you're with tons of different the
thought leaders across industry say we
do on the show and the fact that this is
the first time that we're hearing this
and that I and I try and read as many of
the edge thinking like outlets as well
as possible on the internet and books
and stuff watching videos and it's hard
to find really hard I think to find
people like you that will that are
arguing on behalf of a man to to be in
this position women have more rights
than men in this society right now
quis hosts well I mean no for a for
instance and the legal definition of
rape was changed to where it doesn't
even cover force to penetrate so if say
a woman gets a man intoxicated and
straddles him and you know puts him
inside of her that doesn't meet the
legal definition of rape rape his own
only encompasses being penetrated and
that was changed somewhat recently by
institutionalized feminism which is one
of the large reasons why I oppose it
yeah like sorry you look terrified
yeah well it's extremely terrifying yeah
yeah and you know male genital
mutilation is still you know very common
in this country it's going down but
circumcision we keep on going with you
know men don't male infants aren't
protected the genitals of female infants
arms are protected but the genitals of
male infants aren't protected legally
it's really important to not get
circumcised I think I think I absolutely
agree it adamantly whoa yeah there's no
choice for that child was that yeah
there's I mean that there's they're not
able to make a choice about their own
circumcision at that young of an age
obviously and male suffrage was you know
was it attained by in exchange for the
draft men fought for their own suffrage
you know in exchange for their services
and women fought for that right so long
as they didn't have the same
responsibilities so there's just so many
departments where in
women have more rights than men men are
less protected and they're afforded less
resources they pay more more taxes
they're afforded less resources I mean
just look at the domestic abuse like
shelters and what resources are afforded
to women so much goes to you know women
houses and there's virtually none in the
United States for men they're few and
far between there's some that allow both
sexes but a lot more women same with the
cancers a lot more of our tax dollars go
to the female cancers and very little of
it goes to the male cancers and how is
that fair if men pay more in taxes
interesting whoa
these asymmetries are crazy yeah whoa
and why are they yeah they're so buried
right now under a culture the culture
war oh yeah yeah I guess I guess when
when the matwood majority of propaganda
is majority of culture war let's say
that it's happening seems to be coming
yeah you know you know in a way that it
makes it very difficult to find the
signal that you're talking about right
now like you just gave us like a bunch
of different signal one after the other
that I'd pretty much seen none of in the
culture war right and so that's why yeah
that's why and if you look at like
feminist propaganda they'll complain
like did you know that one out of seven
homeless people are women like you do
you know what the rest of them are
they're men
we're not taking care of men and there's
more female shelters than there are male
shelters I mean of course there's like
the ones that allow both sexes but
constantly if you look at you know
basically all the real problems that a
person can experience in this lifetime
men generally experience it on a much
larger scale and still we always afford
more resources to women now I think it's
okay that we do prioritize the safety
and the security of women as long as
we're being honest about it as long as
we're being honest that you know women
are important and that's one of the
reasons why we've succeeded so well as a
species is because women have a large
gestation period so it's more important
that we protect them and it's more
important that you know they're doing
well and they're happy and that will
help the success of the human race more
when like you know if you look at it
from from an EI standpoint as far as
being effective in like how we afford
our resources yes we do better as a
species and as a society when we afford
more resources to women because the
well-being of women is more pivotal in
the success of our species and society
but we just need to be honest about it
yeah yeah and we need to stop just
throwing men under the bus and
pretending like they're these
predatorial monsters that are just so
well off because they're not men are
suffering and if we're just honest about
it then maybe we can create a stable
system where we say okay yes it's more
important that we help women in these
ways but we also can't let the men drown
because women depend on management and
as we let men suffer
so do the women suffer so we need to be
practical in the way that not only we
decidedly help women more than we help
men but understand that helping men will
also help women totally just like
helping women will help with me more oh
yeah yeah yeah the whole notion
predatorial well off monster that's got
to get the [ __ ] out of our vocabulary
but yeah that's that's torturing the out
of both parties by by doing that type of
stuff yes that does exist in a very
small edge case and we are working on
making better making that better and as
does in the very small edge case I think
on the radical women said yeah the
problem the fact that you just said that
what have every seven people that are
homeless are women it's like yes let's
make that salt but six out of the seven
are men and we have tons right out our
oh and by the way I did I didn't do the
legwork on that statistic so even though
I've heard that statistic before I
haven't really gone through as to
whether or not where they got those
number you may just go walk down the
street and take account yourself and
figure it out because it's very I think
it's extremely evident who the vast
majority of the people that are on the
streets all certainly um okay um I think
you know you'll have to come and read
pull us some more on gender relations
because these this is just you know all
of these signal all these little pieces
of signal that are nowhere very very few
places on the internet I think are
there's a lot to unpack certain yeah
yeah you spent five last five years
doing geriatric care mmm-hmm this is
interesting you were walking with me and
talking with me last week about this you
were like how cool is it to hear stories
from you know seventy years ago and then
you were saying then they're telling
stories about their grandparents which
is another seventy years ago and so I'm
like whoa that's a great way to get
knowledge from what is kind of being
it's it's it's it's it's you're doing
archaeology through people's you know
life stories that is slowly disappearing
into the grave and no one's able to
capture it's not like we're able to take
their brains and
and upload them not yet not yet teach us
about these last five years of doing
geriatric work well firstly I haven't
exclusively done geriatric work I do a
lot of different disability care people
of all ages and so on and so forth so I
wouldn't say that it's always been five
solid years of geriatric care as far as
yeah yeah so I would say it's it's been
really a rich experience to not just you
know learn about history from the
standpoint the way most people do is
where they you know read text books or
they go on Wikipedia and so on it's just
I like ask somebody hey what was the
last time you thought to yourself this
Hitler guys about eggs you know they
were there and they were watching all
this and is interesting to ask them like
how terrified were you when you heard
about you know the h-bomb how terrified
you know how mystified were you when you
saw the man and the moon landing and
it's so while we can collect a lot of
information from you know reading about
these topics it's nice to have that
empathetic moment when you get to have
somebody paint a picture of what
emotionally it's like because you know
there are a lot of things that you know
were true and existed you know before we
were born and so you know that it's not
revolutionary to us it's not new it
didn't doesn't blow our mind we're like
oh okay well this has been around for 20
years this has been around for 50 years
and we just accept it but what's
interesting is to be able to talk to
somebody who was around when those
pivots happened and when those
experience happened the same way that
you know say in the future somebody's
gonna ask me you know what was it like
when you know there weren't cell phones
and if you know if you couldn't find
somebody or somebody you know was you're
supposed to meet somebody you just had
to communicate really well as to where
you were gonna meet what time and so on
and so forth and you know people if you
wanted to make a phone call you had to
be home
if you wanted to be in touch with people
UN to you know see them firsthand and so
the way that we are gonna be able to
tell those stories about how the pivots
in our lifetime have changed things and
how mystified and how odd we've been
yeah by all these pivots like it's been
very enriching to have that exposure to
people with people who are around other
times of innovation and other parts of
history where I get to ask you know what
was it like to witness that what was it
like to you know hear this speech to you
know have that change happen yeah the
the the way you're describing it's so
cool because you're talking about these
like inflection moments for people of
like being mystified or being an are
being a fear and and really getting some
juicy stories of what that what that's
like so that you so we completely
different than reading it on on an
article and then also working with
disabilities as well this is another
moment of like getting behind the eyes
of people that may not have the same
privilege level privileges as we do in
full functionality so this is very
important will you
you know you referenced it just a moment
ago with upload and you were talking
about the very beginning with a I take
what are you tell us about how you're
just you're totally cool with the AI
you're ready for robot takeover like oh
yeah I'd be thrilled if AI were around
to help us make a lot more decisions I
mean we're already automating a lot of
our choices that we make and you know
like probably the first example of ones
that we did was you know we have a
calculator and that makes it a decision
for us like how much do we tip and so on
it you know it does the math better than
you do and because of that it's able to
make the choice that you still want to
make you still have your own autonomy in
that but the automation of like the
functionality of the calculator allows
you to allows it to in a sense assist
with that decision and I think that
we're going to be able to expand more on
that and I'm really looking forward to
that being implemented into you
government policies where we can have
the the checks and balances and the
assurance of you know somebody who
doesn't have their own self-interests
and can be more selfless and be more
defending of person to person while also
being more educated and/or being a
little bit more conscious about like
what what the natural progress of things
will be or should be so the so the
artificial intelligence entering into
Indus to the industries and into our
lives in ways that are have we have yet
to really even imagine how are going to
just significantly benefit our lives
you're just very excited for you oh yeah
I would love I would love to see those
things implemented more and more in time
yeah yeah likewise especially especially
biometrics is a very exciting one for me
I just I want I want I want to know when
I'm having any kind of pathology
starting to develop to just tackle it
before it gets obviously yeah I would
love to see it what's like doctors it's
I mean yeah it's actually in a lot of
cases that you know automation and AI
and certain things like that they're
already out competing doctors were just
not implementing it yet yeah and it
would be nice to see that happen I yeah
I'm little why should a reason to not
die first the first generation did not
died last last generation too or maybe
the G last generation to die we may not
be exact
yeah this has been awesome let's ask you
a couple quick questions online okay on
the way out first question is are we
alone in the cosmos I think I touched on
this a little bit earlier but my theory
is that we are not alone and that
intelligent life
meets the threshold where they ascend
their biological state and I think that
we will make contact and will be able to
interact with other intelligent life
once we ascend our own biology yes yes
yes you call it ascend why do i ascend
instead of transcend biology I it just
suited me just suited you okay okay all
right I'm just trying to figure out what
because I think like I guess it's a
little bit it's a little bit of a double
entendre relative to the question in
that the that ascension is you know us
you know going out into the cosmos and
meeting the other life so I think that
ascend just always felt more apropos to
me relative to not just what it would
accomplish but where it might take us
mm-hmm
hmm just imagine just you know landing
over and a couple you know solar systems
down in the stream like what's up guys
they're like oh you finally made it like
oh yeah I could imagine all the extra
like beauty that we're gonna be able to
see you know different colors and
sunsets oh yeah different types of
species you know that's my that's all my
favorite stuff different species yeah
different yeah coded life-forms yeah
binary stars yeah and what's more
exciting different types of physics
yes we're constraint to the physics of
our you know of our own planet and of
our own solar system but you know
there's completely different laws of
physics out and you know different parts
of the universe in different universes
so yeah not only will there you know be
other things other life and other you
know aesthetic existences but a
functionality of things will be
different because isn't it so fun in a
video game where the physics are a
little screwy and you got to do really
ballistic things that just you can't do
on this planet yeah yeah yeah those sand
boxes where you can change the mass
the code as you play oh yeah yeah yeah
that's that simulation right that's why
we run the simulation in our head of
what that's like are we in a simulation
I don't believe that we are but I think
that we should rule under the assumption
that we are because I think you make
smarter decisions
tell us why well I think that people get
too emotional and too attached and if
you if you go under the principle or if
you work under the idea that maybe
you're in a video game then you can
actually focus on the future and making
progress as well as your own happiness
and I think too often do we let
ourselves be held back by you know
you're trying to win and different you
know biological constraints and get tied
up in all of these thoughts and these
feelings but if you experience that
detachment I think you're able to make
more objective decisions so while I
think we're not in a simulation I think
we should runner the assumption that we
are just if for nothing else I think it
would lead to better choices and happier
lives
interesting so running that you are a
character in a video game and you want
to level up and you want to to not maybe
emotionally attach yourself so much to
something but rather keep an open mind
and also be something will help you
level up faster so it maybe it gives you
a destiny to look forward to everyday
what do you want potentially you just
get less hooked on on the past like I
mean how much how much time do you spend
in a video game like if you already
completed a quest you know going back
and being like oh well you know I didn't
you know I don't really want to do this
next course because you know I didn't
really do so good on that last quest and
now I'm kind of feeling bad but like no
we would enjoy the challenges and enjoy
you know getting past certain things and
I think that it just it allows you to
have a better attitude on life and
be a little bit make better progress yes
yes
stop rewinding old miserable quests
something that I think we do a lot of
last question and what's the most
beautiful thing in the world oh gosh
I'm kind of I'm kind of a sucker for
babies I'm a little baby crazy and so I
just I I think you might have even seen
at the restaurant there was like a baby
over at the other table and Alston I
just like locked in Lock good like the
big neoteny eyes and the cute little
Madame Alexander doll lips I just mmm
yeah
so I think you know babies and children
and just I mean you know as an adult you
know Christmas becomes less fun and then
all of a sudden a new kid comes in the
family like you get a new niece or
nephew and they get older and it's
magical to them again and you get to
experience that magic just adolescence
entirely it's just a very beautiful
thing yeah yeah you imagine if more of
the mimetic sorcerer's spent a little
bit more time with the babies and
children